okay
i just got done carrying all this stuff
up these stairs
let me know if you guys are interested
to see more behind-the-scenes videos
like this one i'm getting ready to show
you okay
everything's changing
stairs are kind of steep everything's
changing guys um
you know i got to be honest i'm i'm a
little bit nervous about this but at the
same time i'm really really excited oh
check this out
i rented some office space
[Laughter]
i rented some office space and uh this
is really really exciting so a lot of
you guys always wondered how
i record my videos by the way i just
moved into this space so i still need to
set up like the green screen and
everything but um these these two lights
right here that one right there and that
one over there um that those are the uh
120ds
and then those are the aputure light
dome twos that are on there
um this is the canon c200
this is what i record on uh that is a 16
to 35 millimeter lens
uh that is
a
mke
uh no
mkh 416 microphone and that's actually
what the microphone mounts to right
there although i guess i could get a
stand these two stands right here are
called c-stands those are guys who are
curious like that one and then this one
those are actually called c-stands i
don't know why they call that because
they don't look like c's but uh in any
event
so you're probably wondering why it is
that i got some office space right why
did i get office space
because i like the idea of one
separating my work life for my home life
let me turn this around real quick
but two
it's i want to expand out i want to do
other stuff right so i told you guys i
was taking applications for people um to
be on geek culture explained for
um
for an app i'm sorry for an anime or
manga podcast
and this is where i would be shooting it
that's why i said i wanted you guys to
be local if you were going to apply so
like in greeley longmont fort collins
loveland that kind of area uh because
this is where i'll be recording this
room in particular is where i would
likely shoot it at um this room's it's a
lot bigger than it looks it's a pretty
pretty big size room but certainly big
enough for you to fit you know a bunch
of people in here and let me flip this
around one more time but enough that you
could fit in like a table and and have
and i'd probably like cover the walls
and you know some kind of uh material i
don't know you know some soundproof
curtains or something like that to
basically you know take the sound out
and then basically record the podcast
here um but this this whole office space
this is not a permanent thing this is a
one year experiment right this is a one
year test to see whether or not i want
to do this um for the long haul and if i
do i'll keep it going and if i don't i
won't so that's why i'm not really
making any major changes to this office
space
the reason why is because if you go
through and you make changes to office
spaces say for example i ripped up all
this carpet
and say it was like the original
hardwood under which it probably is and
say we like refinished it right so we
sand it down we refinish it all that
kind of stuff they keep it right we
don't get any of that stuff back so it's
not like we can go to them and we can
say okay
you know we invested fifteen thousand
dollars in fixing up this office we want
that money back no whatever changes you
make stay with the property so uh that's
why if you're gonna like remodel a whole
office
you do that with space that you own
it's like going in and remodeling an
apartment like
you don't own it unless it's a condo you
don't own it so it's literally just
fixing it up for them right you're just
putting more money in their pocket and
that's ultimately what would happen it
would increase the value of this and
they could start asking for more rent
and i would get nothing out of it
outside of just being in a really pretty
space so um so yeah this is just a
one-year test if at the end of this one
year i don't like it i don't want to
continue it and i'm finished with it
then it just goes back we take it all
back to to the uh to the house and just
start recording in the basement again
fingers crossed it doesn't get to that
point um you know i'm really hoping that
i enjoy
having my my work and my my personal
life separate you know kind of
maintaining that work-life balance i'm
really hoping that happens and we'll
find out over the course of this whole
year so
yeah man uh things are changing man
things are growing and and i'm really
excited about it i'm i'm really really
excited about this idea of geek culture
explain just kind of getting an office
space and and changing it and shifting
it around and all that kind of stuff and
recording so i need to go back home and
get some more stuff i need to bring it
back i'm actually gonna do dinner with
mariah
and then um i'll grab the rest of this
and then you know bring it back probably
later on tonight or maybe tomorrow
morning and uh yeah so thanks for
watching guys and i will catch you all
later
peace